for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out moof
university comm thank you and enjoy
okay so previously we mentioned that
glutamine could and would be transported
all over the body via the blood stream
and the question here is what happens to
the glutamine once it gets to the liver
well the glutamine is transporting
nitrogen basically right and so it
specifically NH 4 plus so if that NH 4
plus that's basically on glutamine is in
excess when it gets to the liver that
glutamine can be converted into
glutamate and NH 4 plus free NH 4 plus
by an enzyme called glutamine ace
glutamine ace so that reaction workers
start with glutamine and we're gonna get
glutamate and so we're basically just
gonna remove that purple amino group
it's not really an amino group it's not
attached to an amide we're gonna remove
that purple nitrogen portion from
glutamine to give glutamate and so it's
a simple hydrolysis reaction which tab
water and we free up that ammonium ion
and of course glutamate catalyzes that
reaction or sorry glutamine ace
catalyzes that reaction and so that that
free ammonium ion can basically go
through the areia cycle to produce urea
where is this reaction happening but we
just mentioned it happens in the liver
but it's specifically the liver
mitochondria which is why you can I
eventually go to the urea cycle and
produce urea now further the glutamate
still has a nitrogen on it that
glutamate can undergo a transamination
reaction in the liver mitochondria to
give alpha-ketoglutarate and some other
amino acid of course paradox of
phosphate would be required for that or
we can have it oxidatively deaminated by
glutamate dehydrogenase to give alpha
ketoglutarate and a free ammonium ion
and that ammonium ion can also go to the
areaa cycle to give urea so that we can
get rid of that excess ammonium ion okay
so that's pretty much it I hope that
video was helpful thank you for watching
if
you found that video helpful don't
forget to Like comment subscribe and
share with friends thank you and happy
studying